another episode of Tekken unlockables
brought to you by ochodo TV
[Applause]
[Music]
the content shown in this video has been
submitted by various players to ochodo
TV Clips are compiled weekly for a
series of videos highlighting specific
players of their gameplay for the Tekken
Community by no means was it reused or
stolen without permission to the
rightful owner
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
thank you
ugly
[Applause]
[Music]
about this
effect
[Music]
what's up
perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
six six
[Music]
come on
on YouTube
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description
TV send in your Clips by following these
steps before you submit your Clips make
sure the quality of the video is clear
put your IGN as a file name for your
video
limit submissions to three to five Clips
a week per category
don't spam submissions and don't send
folders with your Clips on avoid
full-length matches or just cut the clip
you want on the desired play Until the
End of the round
next send your Clips via Dropbox in the
correct category you can always find it
on the description of every ochodo TV
series Once you upload your video file
if it prompts you to give your name just
put in your IGN
also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay match
[Music]
foreign
for some clips to be featured because of
the review process
[Music]